اذا نتعرف على علامات تنبهك ان شريكك
ينسحب من العلاقه العاطفيه وفقا لما يؤكده
اطباء علم النفس اولها توقف الشريك عن
تخصيص وقت لك اذ يصبحوا دائما الانشغال
بامور اخرى تكون في اغلب الاحيان لا قيمه
لها ولا اهميه فهذا غالبا ما يشير الى
الرغبه في الانفصال ايضا ميل الشخص الى
البقاء في العلاقه دون التعبير عن مشاعره
او حتى اخفاء عواطفه ويتجنب تكوين روابط
عاطفيه حقيقيه ثم نتحدث عن بدء الرجل او
المراه في الكذب على الاخر
وكانهما يرغبان في التهرب من العلاقه ما
يمثل فقدان الثقه فيما بينهما ايضا التزام
الصمت والهروب من التحدث عن اي شيء متعلق
بالمستقبل هذا يدل ايضا على الرغبه في
الانفصال ومن العلامات كذلك الانسحاب من
المواجهه او تجنب الانخراط في مناقشات
صعبه ولكن ذات مغزى هذا يساهم في زياده
الانقسام في العلاقه واخيرا عدم بذل الجهد
في الحفاظ على العلاقه العاطفيه او
الزوجيه وانخفاض الرغب في الرغبه في
استثمار الوقت والطاقه والتفكير في رعايه
هذه العلاقه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات